oh my gosh this is
the silver fox himself jordan peterson
is here
i am so excited to finally meet you how
are you sir
hi nicole it's so nice of you to invite
me
i'm i'm very excited so the new book is
beyond order
12 more rules for life we'll flip that
in the screen
uh not to be offensive thank you for
sending it to me but i personally like
this one more than the first one
are you hearing that a lot um i'm
hearing that
more than i expected and i'm happy about
that i mean
you hope that each thing you do is
somewhat better than the last thing you
did if you're fortunate
and it wasn't obvious to me that it i
couldn't tell
if it was the same quality worse better
i tried to make
it better uh and i would say
that's the general response so far yay
it's like michael jackson putting out
thriller and then putting out thriller
two
and thriller two is somehow better so
yay for you i love it
okay what we're going to do today is 12
questions
with jordan peterson to celebrate 12
more rules
are you ready everybody always
celebrates more rules
everybody always celebrates more rules i
love rules because then i get to break
those rules
just like you talked about with the
harry potter characters which we're
gonna get into
okay here we go rule the first no i'm
just kidding question the first
and i just want you to be honest with me
if you could kill anybody
and get away with it like off with their
head queen styles
just one person who would it be
[Music]
i don't think i can answer that question
you mean in my darkest
fantasies i won't tell anybody
i don't i have no idea how to answer
that nicole that's a lie i can see you
thinking of someone in your head but
that's okay we'll skip to the second
question
i had a feeling okay how do you
like your steak cooked medium rare
to medium barbecued barbecue
specifically
well it's best barbecued i think i have
a barbecue in the backyard and use it
all the time
are you a good barbecuer um yes
okay and i watch the meat very carefully
and i don't let it
play flame up and cover it with charcoal
and
and dirt and and and that horrible oily
grit you get sometimes in a barbecue and
i worked in lots of restaurants and so
and i miss cooking because i eat so
little now it's just meat still
but uh but i'm careful with the meat
that's i'm not that good i got my dad a
tomahawk steak last year for father's
day
and it flamed all the way up the
barbecue up the side of the house
right right well yeah that's generally
not good you don't want your
barbecue incinerated or cremated um
that's a whole different thing
right i agree okay next question um can
i eat steak with you sometime
anytime you're near yeah all right
i feel like i'm winning this interview
already once restaurants open again
or i could barbecue you one would you
barbecue me a steak
i suspect i probably would yes
i suspect that would be [ __ ] awesome
okay
oh i'm a fan i'm sweating i have been
around a-list celebrities i've been at
the emmys i've been all these
around all these rock stars and all
these crazy people and everyone asks me
who the one person is that i would
fangirl over
and i always say it's jordan peterson so
i'm having like
a hard time right now i'm sorry if it's
awkward for you have that professionally
evaluated i would say
not the sweating the the fangirling yes
yeah
aren't you a professional evaluate that
quickly for me i'm just going to
evaluate it as flattering and and assume
that you're
credible in your evaluations
it's based on listening to your own
stuff so yeah it's
i think it's pretty good um do you know
what a milf is
yes okay we don't have to say it out
loud so then you know where the filth is
a dilf yeah i i think i can guess
okay what i'm you're pretty smart so i'm
sure you got it
so you're being you know people say that
you're kind of in like that silver fox
range do you know what a silver fox is
it's preferable to dead fox or senile
fox
yeah well it's more of like the george
clooney like
hot older man who's intelligent and
awesome
you get put in that range a lot and i
totally get it
not trying to flirt with michaela's dad
because that's weird but i'm just
i'll bring her in on this and sicker on
you no that's
michaela's my friend that would be so
strange um but
how does it feel to be put as like an
intellectual
like sexual superhero in that way like
you get
like that category
well i can't say that i've dwelled on
that
intellectual sex symbol status jordan
peterson
has that ever occurred to you
not consciously let's say look i can
tell you one okay i'll tell you uh yeah
okay okay omega watches contacted me
um two years ago and they asked me to be
a spokesperson
and at the same time they had
uh daniel craig daniels it's craig
daniels right
james bond daniel craig sorry yeah yeah
it's okay opposite dad
and i thought yeah that would
that would be cool that i had to that
got me i thought
i it would be something i'd never
imagined
but to be on a billboard for omega
watches
when dan when when daniel craig is also
their spokesperson
you know yes that was very flattering
and i i was very very
tempted to do it i didn't you do it
well there was a variety of reasons i
wasn't sure it was appropriate that
i mean there was a fun element to it you
know and and
and and it was really attractive for
that reason and there was a surreal
element to it because it wasn't
something i expected at all
and but i i felt that it would i was
ambivalent about it i suppose not and
it's funny because i actually own an
omega watch now i got it as a present
and i have
three or four watches but i wear this
one and i like it
so um and it's interesting to me that i
wear it because i didn't expect to
but i feel like you over thought your
way out of that awesome opportunity
well a lot of other things were
happening at the same time too that
would have complicated it so it wasn't a
straightforward
it wasn't a straightforward decision but
it was something i was
i was very tempted to do it was very
flattering and very unexpected
and so my support right now
you know it's very difficult to say but
i would probably come to the same
decision
i'm i'm a little bit i would be a little
more tempted to do it now because
i actually have an omega watch and i
actually wear it and like it whereas
before i wasn't familiar with the brand
and i'm not averse to i'm not averse to
capitalistic enterprises let's say yeah
yeah well but i also have to be i strive
to be very careful
in what i do and i and so
that you know i was talking to stephen
fry yesterday and he's an
extraordinarily admirable person in
every regard and he's done all sorts of
advertisements it worked out
fine for him and i don't have anything
against it per se from a moral
perspective but
in the position that i'm in as much as i
can understand that position
i have to be very careful with what i do
and so
if i'm doubtful i tend to say no
when in doubt leave it out that's what i
try and stay with as well
just for a general life rule if i was
writing my own 12 rules
when in doubt leave it out however i
firmly believe that we need more
intellectual rock stars
we have a-holes up on billboards selling
whatever we need some people to look at
the younger generations can look at and
be like that's a badass i want to be
like them i want to get that watch like
them
they're intelligent they have good moral
values they've
come through hardships that's what i
think you could exemplify so maybe think
about it again
you know i don't work for omega you're
sure about that eh
yeah yeah i don't i don't work for them
but i'm just saying
we do need some more badass people to
look up to that
you know if you were on the front cover
of people magazine's sexiest
man of the year and it's because you're
smart and do intelligent things and
share wisdom
i think that's [ __ ] badass so might
be a different way to look at things
just saying yeah i'm listening very
carefully
good i'm glad i taught you a thing
jordan
okay um so i asked you that one oh you
know what there's there's something
about what you said that's right like
i was talking to um yeah say that again
for all the guys i used to take
jacquel willink two weeks ago and i'm
going to release a podcast with him soon
and it was a really fun conversation and
he is this you know monstrous character
unbelievably physically
intimidating and strong and also
that psychologically and
characterologically um
and he we had a very intense discussion
about literacy
and he's the perfect person to have it
a credible intense discussion of
literacy and he really insisted on it he
told me that he got an english degree
and i kind of skipped over it and
in in the conversation and he said i i
want to
i'm surprised that you didn't point out
the
surprising element of me pursuing an
english degree after i had been in the
navy seals
and so we went down that particular road
and then he made this incredibly
powerful aggressive case for
the value of literacy and it was
extremely useful
and he isn't the sort of person that you
see doing that and when you see someone
like that doing that it's
really powerful exactly
exactly so in my perfect world there
would be
jocko's and jordans those are the people
that i would love to see
on the billboards instead of just some
singer who can hit some notes
singing someone else's song that wrote
it who's actually the intelligent
musician behind it but they're not cute
enough
to promote the single so they got some
singer guy to do it
and now he's on the cover of the
magazines he's selling the watches
and this is who society looks up to
there's another element of this that's
worth talking about i think too
is that i've been thinking a lot about
the idea of casual contempt
when i watch people fail
one of the ways that they fail is by
being casually contemptuous of something
so they don't know anything about it and
they're not good at it
but instead of no noting that their own
inadequacy and noting that there's an
opportunity there and that the people
who are pursuing it
actually know something they get
casually contemptuous of it
dismiss it and then they can't then and
so here's a
here's some places i've seen that so
college professors are casually
contemptuous of business people
okay there's jealousy in there and
there's envy
but there's there's also this disdain
for their
domain of of of expertise let's say and
and maybe some anti-capitalism mixed in
just for good moral measure
but the business people are frequently
contemptuous of academics because
they're in their ivory tower and they're
protected and they have a secure job and
all they have to do is lecture you know
two courses a week and
how easy is that so they're each
casually contemptuous and then
they can't learn from each other and so
that means the academics for example
aren't
and then within business maybe you'll
have the engineers and they'll be
casually contemptuous of the sales and
marketing people and they're casually
contemporaries of the engineers
and it's not helpful at all and so
i'm not contemptuous of sales and
marketing
and i'm not contemptuous of advertising
because sales and marketing and
advertising are all forms of
communication
yes and you should get good at them and
then you can communicate and if you have
ideas you need to communicate them and
if you're no good at sales and marketing
let's say then you're no good at
communicating
so what you're saying is you're going to
do the omega app
it does kind of come back to that
doesn't it myself in comedy
i ended up in the marketing and
advertising world because i could convey
messages better than brands could
because they were coming from it at
sales
and i came to it as what are we giving
the audience
entertainment edutainment advertisement
make them laugh make them feel something
connect to their lives
and then they'll want our products or
services and all these suits couldn't
get that so the little blonde girl when
i was 22 had to go into the molson
office and explain it to them
and say you know stop being so
inauthentic let's actually give people a
dope ass party and bring in their best
artists
okay so you mix two things there you
said stop being so inauthentic
and let's be so what how do those two
things go together the
the authenticity and the entertainment
how do you see that
operating together i believe when you
invite people over to your house you
want them to have a great time
you want to put on a great event party
dinner party whatever
that's hospitality hospitality yeah okay
that's what advertising is missing
and marketing you should genuinely want
to entertain
and provide value to your audience with
entertainment
edutainment or you know just having a
good time if you're throwing a big
party or whatever from molson for nike
whoever it is
okay and what's what's the where's the
authenticity piece in that as far as
you're concerned
actually caring about people actually
yeah that it actually matters to you
yeah because right you're just a number
and they're just a dollar
you don't give a [ __ ] but if you
actually care about providing something
awesome and an awesome experience and
building a community
even though it's buzzwords now around
your people they're gonna feel that
they're gonna keep coming back to buy
your product
or they're gonna at least tell someone
else to get your product and i think
people feel the same way about you
you provide an experience you're you're
a badass renegade in these interviews
around the world
you stick to your guns that's an
experience for us you give us
edutainment not just the the facts i'm
entertained when i see you go against
someone
that i know can't possibly touch you
it's really fun to watch
um and then you know you have any idea
why it's entertaining
um because you pick a team for
i'd say for you it's entertaining
because i pick a team
and i picked your team because i saw you
as sense
versus the growing nonsense so
if i could buy jerseys with peterson on
the back
and musk i would but they don't sell
those and i'm not that into sports
so instead i promote your book
i tell my fans to follow you i i love
elon musk and i promote him well you
know we have a murder we have
we have a merchandise section and this
is why it came about yeah it's on my
youtube channel and
i've been ambivalent about it too but
but i but i'm not
and what happened was that as
my popularity or notoriety or or or
reprehensibility
i think they all go together well
apparently they do um
as as that expanded people started
offering merchandise
all over the place t-shirts and and and
stickers for your computer and posters
and and
a lot of it was very creative and
original and
there was a lot of it and i thought at
one point well
there's obviously a demand for this and
so then you ask yourself well
when you're trying to communicate with
people and you know there's a demand
what's the appropriate thing to do and
you might say
and and this is a question worth asking
well that's not the manner in which
you've chosen to communicate and that's
not your bailiwick and
stay out of it and don't cheapen the
message and don't sell out and all of
that
buzzword those are all cliches those
though like all cliches they
carry a kernel of truth it's something
to watch for so we set up a merchandise
and which my son
runs and partly that was also an
experiment because i'm always curious
about how things work and so we thought
well
let's do this and see what happens and
we have posters and
and mugs and and
tights with lobsters on them and that's
so funny
they're also it's also funny there's an
element of foolishness about it
and that's the place where the ideas
meet the popular culture but
nothing bad has come about and i've left
the merchandisers who aren't me alone
like i think if you can take something
that i've
done and you can figure out how to
package it and you
make a certain amount of money on that
and you're not
you know you're not twisting what i'm
doing and you're not bending it and
exploiting it um that's fine go go right
ahead
and i don't see any problem with that at
all in fact i
would wear a piece of grip i would i
would if there was a jersey
like an actual sports jersey it said
peterson if there was like an
intellectual league that we could almost
have our teams and wear those jerseys i
would totally do it that'd be fun
but at the same time for years i didn't
have merch
that said nicole arbour on it because
i think one part i thought it was
pompous and one part i was almost
insecure about selling stuff yeah well
that's exactly what i'm telling
talking about is that casual so with you
it wasn't so much casual contempt it was
maybe lack of confidence
it's like who wants to put my name on
their body it turns out a lot of people
that's interesting and so what do you
think about that
you've obviously decided to do it and
why did you think that that was
either okay or desirable and how did you
how did you settle your moral qualms
well i went back to quality and giving
them that hospitality experience
if people want to cheer for me and be on
my team my whole thing is go team
i that's my mantra that's what my fans
are i don't have
fans i have a team and i can cheer for
fans either
i have viewers and listeners and
watchers and readers
i don't have fans yes and i don't want
fans
i like walking down the street and
running into people who enjoy what i do
and they just want to have a
conversation they don't always just want
to scream
i'll fangirl for you and you need to let
me have my moment because it's the only
one
i'll do but in general it's i can cheer
for you because i'm awesome too
i want everyone who follows me to be
successful i don't want to be put up on
some strange pedestal
i want it to all be friends i haven't
met yet and
if my friends want to wear a shirt with
one of my slogans on it because it makes
me feel like a badass
let's do it if it makes them feel
awesome let's do that if they want to
buy the lipstick that i always wear
because that's them being part of my
team let's do it i've just reached the
point where i'm like yeah let's
however you want to cheer for me and be
part of this team i'm going to help you
do that
so we're also looking really hard at the
whole
social media universe and this is again
a sales and marketing issue in some
sense but really it's a communication
issue
it turns out and you probably know this
already that
one of the things that makes video
really different than
text is that you can cut video into very
small sections and it still
works it's like you can it's as if you
could as if you could
sell a book by the sentence and there's
all these forms that have popped up
instagram and tick tock that that focus
on video lengths of a video of a certain
length
well that's also a communication mode on
twitter of course is was famous for 140
characters you get these weird
limitations
that produce all these opportunities and
so we're actively
going through my current interviews and
my back catalog
finding one minute pieces two minute
pieces five minutes
of course people are doing this all by
themselves because i saw at one point
and i think this is still happening that
about 200 videos a day
are being made and posted up on on
youtube
from my video content not my team but
people just doing that and so
so that's an also an in interesting yet
in that in the classic hero mythology
which
i think classic hero stories are
reflections of um optimal human behavior
the hero goes out into the unknown or
fights a tyrant
those are the two main themes goes into
the unknown and comes back with
something of value like the hobbit
um going off to fight the dragon and
coming back with the gold but
that's only half of the hero story the
other half is the distribution of what's
been found to the community
so it's productivity and generosity
that's one way of thinking about it or
it's
um exploration and finding the treasure
but then
sharing it and hopefully sharing it so
that it grows and
the communication part is just as
important as the exploration
and discovery part and and if you have
casual contempt for the communication
forms then you can't communicate and
it's a really bad time to have that
casual contempt because all these new
communication forms are emerging
out of breath taking piece isn't it fair
to say you maybe had some of that casual
contempt for social media at the
beginning
but now you guys are more getting into
it no i don't think so i think
but there's a reason for that so i have
a product
before i became well known i produced
this software to
help people write about their lives to
write about their past and their present
and their future it's
the self-authoring program and um
i believed when i first made my first
products
that if you made a good product it would
sell itself
so i figured the product problem was 95
of the problem but after
trying to sell various things especially
the corporations
for like 10 years with really no success
and i mean
zero i realized that
product is like five to fifteen percent
of the problem and
sales and marketing which is
communication is 85
and i lost any contempt i had for sales
and marketing right then because i
realized it was unbelievably difficult
and absolutely necessary and
when you're creating a product you
should actually be talking to your
market
continually during the process of
product generation to make sure that
you're
something that people want so by the
time
yeah story going to ask my audience as
we go like what designs do you want
what slogans do you want what would you
like this to be i asked them as we go so
that by the time i get there
i'm delivering something they already
wanted there's no reason
right right well yes and i'll test it as
i go you know
exactly well that means that stops you
from producing something that really
works but has no
ecological it has no ecosystem to to
live in
yeah and and that's deadly and so i
learned all these things luckily
although and it was very difficult to
learn them it really took me 10 years of
of failing to learn these things by the
time
all this came along especially after i
had experimented with youtube because
when i started putting my
videos up on youtube um you know it was
a place for cat videos essentially
and so it was a it was it was easy to
to you know it was amateurish and it was
just getting going and
it was before it was bought by google
and no one knew what to make of it and
most of it was cat videos
and so yeah well you know everyone likes
a good cat video and
they're warm and touching and funny and
all of that so fine but
um i started to experiment with youtube
and then i started to understand what it
was and
i still haven't really understood what
it is because it's a revolutionary
technology
video video on demand
everyone's now a tv producer if they
want to be and and there's no barrier to
publication and there's no
administration there's no bureaucracy
there's
there's infinite bandwidth there's the
possibility of dialogues with your
audience like i saw this some one one
thing i had was
released on on i think it was i think it
was tick tock
but i might be wrong um i think you can
do these things called duets on tick
tock
yes yes so someone will we should do a
duet on tick tock i'm just saying but go
ahead
well i just found out about them but but
they're part of the
a conversation with the audience so
michaela and i were talking about
this finding that if a
for every 15 points a woman's iq goes up
over a hundred
she has 35 percent less chance of being
married
and the reverse is true i was going to
talk to you about this because michaela
and i have discussed this as well
and i i tried to push back on her i'm
like no
because my iq is doing quite well i'll
say it that way
um and you know the dating stuff i've
found it hard because i have
dated people who are very intellectual
and
maybe you know in the looks area they're
not what someone would expect me to be
with
and they eventually get upset with the
way i look or that people say
you guys don't match together like i
don't i don't get it you must have money
or something
but they were an intellectual match for
me and then when i kind of dumbed down
to date someone else i end up getting
bored
really easily so yeah do i have any hope
jordan can you introduce me to someone
well i can't there's no one i can think
of that i can introduce you to but i've
worked with
women who have who have expressed
exactly the same issues that you've just
expressed and
so also the duet issue well let's get
back to that issue we will but
the issue was interesting because
mikhail and i were discussing it it was
only about a 30-second clip or
a minute on tick-tock i believe and then
there were all these duets
of women watching this and responding
and i thought well that's so cool
you know you think well that's trivial
but it's not it's not trivial because
all of a sudden video has become
something that
enables a dialogue and for my entire
life video was a one-way street
right it was the television station out
to the consumer
but now it's a dialogue and so it's
awesome
these technological revolutions
are masked by their apparent triviality
but they're not trivial they're
fundamental they're fundamentally
revolutionary and so we're attending to
all these social media forums and trying
to master them because they're
they're very sophisticated modes of
communication and if you have casual
contempt
so because we thought through some of
the things that you're talking about you
know you're talking about you know
intellectual esports who are rock star
all of that it's like
well how about ideas that are
advertisements yes
maybe i can teach someone i can teach
someone something in 30 seconds
yeah so fine so fine then there's the
30-second niche
on tick-tock because is anyone making
one-minute idea videos and the answer to
that is essentially
no they're creative they're down and
maybe there are
many many people that i don't want to
see you twerk but no offense but
right well yes yeah i don't want to see
that either
definitely i i don't know who does well
maybe there's a niche maybe they're on
tick tock
there's undoubtedly a group out there
who would like that
too much because out there is a group
that likes anything
too much let's not service them that's
like
that's why i never have bare feet in any
of my photo shoots
or i try not to because too many people
have asked me for feet photos
over the years that i think is a little
strange i don't want to give that to
them
that sounds that sounds wise to me that
might be something you don't want to
cater to
thank you okay i would love to fly
through a couple of these quick
questions so i have it to clip together
and then circle back to the question
about the dating stuff sure
you good all right so this is a fun one
for me
i've noticed that angry unmarried ugly
women don't like you
and write cruel articles or fiction
about you
there's not really a question i just
wanted to say it out loud for you
oh god okay okay that's all okay
next one i think that shocked me so
badly that you might have to repeat it
just so that i'm sure that i got it
anyways no problem i've noticed that
angry unmarried ugly women don't like
you and write cruel articles of fiction
i just wanted you to know that i've
noticed it that's well not even a
question
but i would like you to know that if you
want me to fight someone for you
i'll do it like i'm like pretty good
that also might be an audience that you
don't want to cater to
fighting on behalf of jordan peterson i
was
oh yeah i don't want to do that but i
just wanted you to know that i noticed
what kind of people consistently write
hateful articles about you
i wouldn't want to be their friend
anyway so don't worry okay
next question what's it like having a
badass daughter
well it's been it's been a lifesaver
literally yes that's awesome
cool literally yeah michael is amazing
and yeah well gold michaela you know i
mean it worries me because she is she's
like you in many ways she's extroverted
and enthusiastic
and and open all of those things and
people it's easy to make because you're
doing many things you're very
curious and maybe somewhat disagreeable
um
you and you need that to be a comedian
often um
because you have to you have to say
things that aren't polite to be a
comedian
you have to do that um it's easy to make
mistakes and so i worry about her making
mistakes
as she's exploring but you know you have
to make mistakes and
i try to listen to her and talk with her
to
feel out the landscape and but she seems
to be
powering along through it and and and so
hooray for that
thanks do you ever get nervous with it i
feel like yes
and he's like ah when i was just like
what are you gonna say
are you are you sure wouldn't you just
want to be an entertainment news host
that'd be so much easier
but there's no way we're nervous all the
time like in a constant state of
of terror because of the scale of
the communication and and also the
vitriolic nature of some of it
you know every time there's a hit piece
of some sort and michaela's been
featured in a couple of those now
again by a woman that's uh you know
i looked up i do it instantly when i see
someone write something negative about
people that i think are awesome
i go i google right away who the
reporter is
i want to see what they post i want to
see their photo
i want to see what their bio is and nine
times
out of ten it is exactly what i want or
exactly what i assumed
and one time it's a an empty bubble and
there's nothing in it and it's a fake
person writing it
so they're either a coward or they're an
[ __ ] and i don't respect their
opinions anyway so
i hope that you guys can take that into
consideration when you read this stuff
about you
this is something else that just
happened this is something else that's
happened
recently that sort of flipped the power
balance
with regards to new media because before
when when i was younger
it was all top down but now
you can do exactly what you just said so
if a journalist writes an article you
can do an investigation into the
journalist
and people absolutely do that and the
younger they are the more likely they
are to do that because
they're at a much more equal place with
regards to their
access to communication technology and
so it's increasingly the case that if
you it it's harder and harder to do
things top down
it's harder and harder and that's that's
all to the good i think
i think it's great i think it's
fantastic there's a level of
accountability to it
that we might not have had before the
internet and being able to search these
reporters
so i like it again i'll fight for you
guys don't worry
okay here's a very this is like a very
very important question
you mentioned harry potter in the new
book
i as a potterhead got very very excited
i also have a marauders map on my wall
because i love it and i also solemnly
swear i'm up to no good
if you were a character in harry potter
who would you be
[Music]
this is so important potterheads are
gonna love this
well i had a certain affinity for snape
i could totally see that i can totally
see that
okay you'd snape it up
he's an interesting character and and
and i think the the
the um actor who played him did an
absolutely brilliant job
yeah that sort of intense darkness and
but i mean he
he he harnessed that for good and my
my experience with men in particular is
that the
best men i ever knew were those who
could have been the worst
but decided not to be yes
that's in unerringly being the case and
they're very respectable but you respect
people like that instantly as soon as
you meet them you think
don't cross him you know that but
but the powers for good right that's
exactly it baby i love that that's a
good answer
okay who do you think is the most
important character in harry potter
i think we might disagree on this so
that's why i'm setting this question up
the most important yep
i love that you're stumped on this
well the i'm i the obvious answer is
harry but
i'm trying to think of an answer that's
useful and not obvious it's hermione
because harry well that's the issue
okay so why hermione in every film it's
hermione saving harry's ass
he would have been dead in the first
film if it weren't for her there
wouldn't even have been
a series so all the way along she helps
him and saves him
guides him teaches him things well it's
funny and i i i
i feel bad that you said that because
that was what i was going to say and now
that i beat you to
it yeah that's right exactly what it is
that's right you got to the punch line
before me
well she's a great role model i mean i
know
rowling didn't write harry potter
characters so that they were role models
because that would be
dull and those books aren't dull and she
captured the imagination of an entire
generation you know i've got a lot of
a lot of the criticism that i've
received from intellectual types let's
say
um have focused on my what would you say
stoned undergraduate interpretation of
harry potter
and i think that's so funny because it's
another example of this casual contempt
you know because
i look at what jk rowling did and i
think okay
look this woman produced seven books
correct is it seven
i believe it's seven yeah i think it's
seven and they're all the ones
they're all this thick they're all two
inches two and a half inches thick
like 500 pages long and every kid read
them or wanted to read them or had them
read to them
and most parents too and she could fill
a stadium and read and so she promoted
literacy like
no one else she dominated the popular
culture for 10 years she produced a
movie
uh enterprise that produced billions of
dollars worth of value
and the movies were very high quality
and entranced and
a whole other audience and it's
absolutely and she was
a single parent if i remember correctly
who was unemployed it's like it's a
cinderella story
and a real cinderella story and it's a
magical story and it had this immense
cultural impact
and people think that the
people who look at my analysis of that
and criticize it
not for its content but for me merely
doing it are so
blind importance of that that
they don't notice that they're missing a
mystery
it's like why did this happen why did
what she do work so well and it's
because
her mythological imagination is perfect
there's something to be said for
fun and being able to cheer for someone
again
you know we got to cheer on multiple
levels within those books which is what
people love to do we got to pick
what house what house would you be in
jordan do you know what house you would
be
well you'd have to be slytherin wouldn't
it i think you'd be a slytherin
i have a feeling that we we would still
be friends
i think what would happen is that i'd
get the sorting hat put on me and that's
what it would suggest and i'd
refuse it perhaps to go where
to slytherin okay slytherin
i've done the tests i'm half slytherin
half gryffindor
so i think i'd have to talk to the hat
as well because i i can go the dark side
i i'm very cunning in that way but i
prefer to be
the happy hero so we get to cheer for
what house we're in we get to cheer for
harry
we get to cheer for good versus evil
there's so much that we get
before with the little kids when the
younger grades start coming up we get to
cheer for them when they fight back
against the bad guys
there's so much to cheer for that it
just sets you on fire it makes
all the underdogs rise and for
intellectuals to not be able to see
that so quickly to me goes back to
intellectuals overthinking which i know
is what intellectuals do
but it's no it's the contempt it's the
refusal to even think about it
you should think about it because it
like clearly because something
happened and she put her finger on
something instead i think about it maybe
they should feel about it
well maybe yeah there's my thoughts oh
harry potter people are gonna love that
clip
okay almost done sir i got your daughter
in there oh here comes some
real question um
okay we have an intellectual one do you
think canada's in trouble
i'm also from canada i'm from hamilton
originally and then toronto for
most of my life do you think canada's in
political trouble right now
no not really things were way more
unstable
when the when the separatist the two
separatist
uprisings let's say occurred i mean the
country could have easily been torn
apart
both times it was very very very close
and it was intense
um i don't think we're in any more
trouble than the west is in trouble
crisis and opportunity fundamentally but
and trouble compared to what
compared to other countries in the world
no
the historical reality no no so
all things considered things are pretty
good
okay i like that answer it makes me
happy and i feel like it's correct
awesome okay now we're gonna go into
something else
i have a theory i'm gonna read this one
because i have to write it down
i have a theory that gender dysmorphia
is similar to body dysmorphia
in that it only exists because we have
something to compare ourselves to
and that young kids wouldn't naturally
be comparing themselves to anybody else
unless someone called them to do it and
that
you know by transitioning every little
boy who wears a dress
into a woman we're actually killing off
what might be the future gay population
did that make sense a bunch of that's a
bunch of questions yeah
there was multiple things in there i can
unpack that first
with body dysmorphia do you feel it
might be similar
that's i would say that's the that would
have been the psychiatric consensus
before the recent rise in political
correctness
cool i thought i just came up with it so
i like hearing that professionals
thought it
okay and then do you believe that if
kids never heard of it
they would they wouldn't be doing it oh
there's all sorts of examples of
psychiatric contagions
so if you read there's a book called
discovery of the unconscious
which is a great book it's a great book
and anybody who's interested in
psychoanalytic thought it's also an
extremely interesting book
he documents the rise and
the contagious rise and then fall of
multiple personality disorder over about
300 years
it cycles and so it ha what happens is
there's a case report
it gets a tremendous amount of attention
then there's all sorts of case reports
it just emerges and and distributes
itself everywhere
and there's hundreds of case reports and
then and then
cynicism about it or criticism of it and
skepticism starts to set in
and then the cases disappear and then
the idea vanishes and then it reemerges
and that happens over and over and
um there are personality
types um histrionic is the technical
term
who seemed particularly susceptible to
psychiatric contagion
now i don't know if that's the case with
what's happening right now but
another example of that is that
generally speaking and i hope i'm i'm
still correct in this uh
um if you put a suicide hotline in a
town
and you start to publicize suicide the
rates go up
not down the same thing happened with
cutting
which is extremely widespread yeah
that's a contagion
yeah it happened with eating disorders
so there's there's a
imagine that people have emote intense
emotional troubles of
of a non-differentiated sort that's
that's common
no matter what the historical time and
place is
let's say the way that manifests itself
is going to be shaped by
the current culture and the cultural
narrative from culture to culture and
within cultures itself and so
there's always this interplay with
psychiatric diagnostic categories
between
the biology and the biological
let's say pathology that might be
associated with an illness and the way
that's expressed
the culture shifts and turns that and
there's there's no doubt that
ideas psychiatric ideas can be
contagious
and i do believe that that's the dane
one of the dangers
in um disturbing
settled ideas of gender is that i smile
when i i'm already agreeing with you and
these are thoughts that i have had
but you are expressing them better than
i knew how i'm smiling like a crazy at
you right now
yeah clearly it's clearly the case that
some people
suffer unduly from a cut-and-dried
gender binary because
there are people many people who don't
fit neatly into those categories
and it is partly because there's a
biological sex
and there are personality traits let's
say that are associated with gender but
not
tightly linked to it so on average women
are more agreeable
but some women are more disagreeable
than some men on average
women are more enthusiastic but some men
are more enthusiastic than some women
and so you can have a man enthusiastic
and agreeable
so he's he's got some feminine traits
and and and the binary distinction is
is harder on people who is hard on some
people fine
fair enough true enough the question is
what happens when you blur the binary
and my suspicion is that
you confuse and hurt far more people by
destabilizing that than you help
i agree that's been my observation
i like to stand back look at what's
happening before i form an opinion as
much as i possibly can without you know
getting emotional
with the internet and that's what i've
seen happening so
i'd like to go to the next part of that
question was
i grew up in dancing and cheerleading
and
lots of little boys would love to put on
the dresses
and they would run around with the fairy
wings and
100 of those boys have grown up to be
gay
and um probably not a hundred percent
of the of the ones i saw in the dancing
the ones that i called it that they were
gay
okay and my mom would be like don't say
that about them
well they're all gay now and the openly
gay happily
married whatever now my thought is that
if we're
every little boy who's putting on a
dress and dancing around and kind of you
know having those same mannerisms
we're now encouraging them to transition
to a woman
is that killing off our future gay
population for a lack of better words to
that discussion that discussion is being
had in the lgbt community
definitely come up with anything
the discussion continues you know it's
not an easy discussion to have
because just having it makes you hated
no matter which side you come down on
and so it's very difficult to have a
discussion when no matter what you
conclude you're going to be hated
yeah that seems to have i mean both of
us i think
i think in some sense that that
conclusion is
virtually inescapable if
the pre-politically correct data
on children with gender dysphoria is
true
because the pre-politically correct data
there's a scientist in toronto who is
pilloried for for
supporting this data but it was this
psychiatric state of the art at the time
and i don't think think's been
superseded by any new knowledge that's
more valid
it was 85 percent i believe of children
with with gender dysphoria
um accept the biological reality of
their body by the time they're 18. and
so
the the the if you accept the
hippocratic oath which is
in some sense uh first do no harm sorry
that might not be the
hippocratic oath i i can't remember
exactly at the moment
but it's it's a medical it's it's a it's
a
one of the hallmarks by which medical
intervention might be justified first do
no harm
um the the appropriate advice for
a parent who has a child with gender
dysphoria is wait
don't do anything radical when the cost
of doing something radical is so high
weight now the pro transition
opposition to that idea would say well
it's so damaging if you wait that you're
actually hurting the child
more than you would if you went ahead
with the radical transition but i don't
think
that evidence on yourself what's that i
don't believe they have the data to back
that up yet
to say that it's going to be so wildly
harmful because we haven't had the test
groups to even conclude that
is going to happen in the future because
this is still a newer issue
ish does that make sense to you that's
how i stand back and look at it is
we don't have the data yet guys so we
shouldn't be making
big giant decisions when we just don't
have the data yet and this is a lot of
kids
there's a lot of kids that are
transitioning now so it's it's an
interest
it's not a trivial matter the transition
now if
you can argue that it's not a trivial
matter to not transition if that's your
destiny and not to do it early but
um i don't think well
i the data suggested that 85 percent of
children with gender separation
accepted their biological reality by the
time they were 18.
so but but a substantial proportion of
them did end
sorry this is and this is the answer to
your question a substantial proportion
of them did end up
gay and so yes if you're transitioning
the more transitioning children
medically
if all of the rest of that is true then
those are children who would have been
gay who have now
transitioned yes that is if those other
propositions are true that is what's
happening we're in trouble already i can
feel it for having this discussion
that happens it just keeps happening um
do you think
i i'm off i'm often in trouble for
having discussions like this too
but do you think you and i maybe are
missing something that we should have
where we should care that people are
upset with us for having these
conversations
well i do care and it's very difficult
for me generally to have these
conversations because
i do understand the uh
anguish let's say that these issues
produce
and and i understand why people are
motivated to
take the positions they take um but
there's there's there's catastrophe on
both sides and so i weigh the
catastrophes and try to pick the route
that's less catastrophic
you know when when i don't think that
the current theories of identity that
are part and parcel of
the culture wars are adequate theories
of identity i think
they will do the people that adopt them
harm now they think well
i'm that person and i don't think it's
harming me and who are you to say and
the answer is well i'm a clinical
psychologist and i've looked at the
literature and i've watched this for a
long time and
that's my professional judgment it's
like i could be wrong
but and your argument is well you have
your experience and
and fair enough you know it's your life
but
but i don't see that it's a good move i
don't well i
certainly don't believe that the theory
of identity that is coherent or
adequate it's it's neither it's
incoherent and inadequate and
your identity isn't merely what you
feel about your sexuality say or even
your even your biological identity
that's
it's silly it feels silly i feel like
we've gotten to the point where
a lot of the arguments are just silly
and the same thing i feel for the people
who these
subjects affect and they affect their
families deeply and everyone's
you know i get that these are big
subjects but i feel like if we can't
have honest conversations
where ideas are explored without
chopping down everybody who might have
an idea
we're gonna get stuck and then there's
no innovation anymore we have to be able
to have these ideas
and you've been so brave with your ideas
i just want to say thank you for that
first of all
yeah and then my last question is i'm
gonna bring it back to
okay this intelligent woman dating thing
help help because i've gone through
the i've gone through the different
things like i said
you know i've dated guys who maybe
aren't as intellectual as myself and i
get bored i get they're super cute and
they're hot and they might be athletes
and they do really well with what they
do
but i'm bored and then i've gone the
other way and i've noticed that they
tend to get
really insecure about dating someone who
might be physically more attractive than
them or people
thinking that that's what that is so i'm
not sure where to sit if people are like
what's your ideal man i'm like i have no
idea
because i'm smart
i think that the data suggesting that
women mate
across and up hierarchies is true
and that men made across and down that
that looks to me to be true it looks
like it's true cross-culturally although
it varies to some degree
and people who are
unfamiliar with that idea or doubt it
you could read bus
the psychologist buss and
he's a credible authority in my
estimation and
so the problem then comes is that
imagine there's multiple dimensions
along which you might evaluate someone's
attractiveness
there's personality there's intelligence
there's athletic prowess there's
socioeconomic status there's productive
capacity
um there's creativity there's lots of
dimensions
so then imagine that you're above
average on
three or four dimensions well that makes
it easier for men because
they're made across and down those
hierarchies but it makes it harder and
harder for women because
with each dimension they're above
average on
if their fundamental desire is to find
someone who's of equal or higher status
they shrink their dating people i know
yeah well that's
i think that's exactly right well i also
think and i've seen this when i've
when i've counseled women who were
intelligent creative and attractive
and young all and that's four like
killer attributes
men were often so intimidated that they
never got asked out
i've noticed that happens a lot too a
lot of my gorgeous amazing talented
female friends
who are just they just kick ass at so
many things guys won't even ask them out
that they go for this hardly because
the closer to your hypothetical ideal
someone you're attracted to
is the more pain you suffer when you're
rejected
so that's why that happens and so
men are a lot more afraid of women than
women think
especially women that they're attracted
to well it's a total rejection right
it's a really
comprehensive rejection you know it's
it's it's you know the the comical end
of it is well you're okay for a friend
but i wouldn't want your genetic
material to propagate itself to the next
generation
that was the nerdiest thing you've ever
said
okay i just imagined you courting mrs
peterson
okay never mind no no fine fine but
so well so it's it's an intractable
problem to some degree
and and you know i think that part of
the reason that
human beings are the way they are it's
part of the reason is because
female human beings are choosy sexual
selectors
unlike chimpanzee females for example
and so
we a fair bit of our evolutionary
development across time is a consequence
of
the high standards that women place on
eligible men but it's harsh and it also
it's it's hard on women
too because well they shrink their
dating pool for example
yeah now what's the solution to that
there's a solution my fan base is
predominantly female
most are college or university grads uh
just saying
they tend to be hot and smart and
awesome and creative
and be in multiple dimensions and i get
the same questions over and over
because they have the same i guess one
of the things i would say to
women who who aren't being asked out
let's say
well do they asking flip it like you
have to take it in
you have to take it into your own hands
like if you're not being asked
figure out what you want this is
something that women
women all everyone should do but let's
talk to young women it's like okay well
first of all figure out what you want
what you actually want and you should
talk to someone
your friends or someone you trust and
and spend an hour figuring out
what you want and try not to lie
to yourself you know do you want kids
and when you're 19 it's fashionable to
say no but that's
likely a lie now it might be true when
you're 19 but the probability that it's
going to be true when you're 29
is almost zero and no one will tell
young women
that it's like i don't care what you
think now that you're 19. you don't
understand
as you mature the desire to have a baby
will become
unbelievably intense and you need to
know that and if you decide not to have
children that's your decision but
you should be informed that this is
what's coming and in all likelihood
you want more you want children more
than you're willing to admit
even at 19. so well all right so yeah
that's what you said
caught this idea that
well motherhood isn't as high status as
an occupation as it should be
that's that's a cultural failing but
we're also you just got so many moms
following you you just got so many more
fans
and just like this you know when my wife
had little kids
it was often the case that she wasn't
well treated in restaurants and so forth
especially if i wasn't there
so and that wasn't good i thought that
was a sign of real cultural sickness
that a mother with a young child isn't
is treated badly that's very bad idea
that's part of this casual contempt so
anyways when you're 18 or 17 or 19 or 22
it's like
what do you want exactly what what do
you want
and that's that's a i wrote about that
in chapter three of
this new book beyond order don't hide
things in the fog you have to let
yourself know what you want
well so you make a list of what you want
and and what is that well you want
someone who's productive and generous
and honest
that's a real good start you want
someone that you're physically attracted
to
yes um you want someone who's
education and intelligence roughly match
or exceed your own
i should stop reading
[Laughter]
daddy peterson's dating rules can't keep
going
well and then if you find someone like
that and
then that's who you want right and and
you should know that and you should
you should notice that because then at
least you're looking in the right place
like there's some
maybe you could also put into one of
your podcasts or things because you i
know a lot of young men follow you
so ask the girls out there i do i
i tell them all the time so i get out
there and ask and say in my clinical
practice too it's like you're not going
to find someone unless you ask and
you know for all their there's a lot of
criticism
uh aimed at the uh um
you know those those the men's movements
that teach men how to be a player
how to attract women how to there's a
lot of negative
press aimed at those and i can
understand why because there's kind of a
psychopathic element to it but
one of the things those movements do do
is to really encourage young men to
overcome their fear of
approaching women and and even asking
them for their phone number for
a date or for a conversation or for a
coffee and
put a profile up on um on a dating
profile
dress up nicely get a professional
photograph taken you know put your best
foot forward
and have enough courage to approach some
women and maybe
get over your fear and yeah it's so
but i would say to young women if you
find someone who you think
fits your criteria and you're not being
asked out
ask them fine i'll do it and i will
report
what's the alternative to wait and
wither on the vine
that doesn't seem very useful i don't
want to do that
no that sounds horrible i didn't want to
say horror but then i did
dang it okay no i don't want to do that
i love that thank you so much i have a
question for you and this is a stupid
question
perhaps but no go i've been very curious
about
apps like tinder and i talked to abigail
schreier about this
the other day because there's some
evidence that young people are having
much less sex than they were
20 years ago um and so
i've wondered with with apps like tinder
if
if what's happening is that a small
number of men
are getting a tremendous amount of
sexual attention from women and a huge
number of men are getting none at all
and the guys that are attractive say on
tinder
then have their selection they have
women who've already said yes
because that's the only people you
communicate with on tinder if i if i
understand it correctly um and so
they have all these women at their
disposal essentially and then almost no
incentive
unless they're mature to have a
committed relationship
and so that puts the women in a terrible
bind too because the men that they find
attractive are
uncatchable in some sense because the
competition level is too high and i i
have no idea if that's true if that's
actually something that is happening
i feel like it's partially true i feel
like there's that level to it
exactly what you just said but then
there's also a psychological element
that i think we aren't discussing which
is that
men aren't necessarily attracted to uh
prey that walks up to them and lays down
dead
the hunting is gone so i feel like a lot
of times men can swipe and know i i can
hook up with this girl this girl this
girl tonight well
maybe that's another conundrum it's like
so
and i'm too old to be involved in any of
this so i don't understand it anymore
but
um if tinder
for example facilitates hookups yep
what happens if you're if you go on a
tinder date and you're female and
you say no like are you out of the pool
then are you no longer
so are you pushed constantly for instant
sexual
sexual favors let's say
tinder is hook up central that's what
you're going on tinder for
hinge is more looking for a relationship
maybe more okay so they're sorting
themselves out the apps
sorting but there is there's there's
levels to it for sure where there are
certain apps like yeah if you're not
going to hook up with them you don't
meet up with them
that's what that's for this is our
instant sex app and then see i just
can't see that being
i don't think that's in anybody's good
interest i but i particularly think it's
not in the good interest of young women
i also don't think it's in the good
interest of young men because
i think it teaches them to be
psychopathic predators
fundamentally no i mean that i mean that
i mean
there's any way out of this because if
you're
if you repeatedly practice taking sexual
intimacy
out of the broader context that's what
you're practicing
well how is that not it's it's shallow
because it's shallow by definition
because
it's only the pursuit of hedonistic
pleasure decontextualized you don't know
the person you don't know their story
you're not
involved in an ongoing adventure you're
not contributing to one another's lives
you're not dependent on each other
there's no relationship there so
it's just a quick hit yep it's a quick
content
contextless hit well so then what what
is it so
then is it if you practice interacting
with women
but also with men if you're a woman as
if they're a source of instant context
free gratification
how are you not training yourself to
treat human beings as if they're
nothing but instant sources of context
free
um gratification which is the same as
the porn addiction which is why i also
feel like men are having less sex
is because they can just go on to any
porn site at any time of day
or even instagram and see these all
these porn stars and naked women
get what they wanted out of a you know
an interaction with a woman
do it themselves and then they have no
reason to go on a date they already got
off
they don't care and this is what i feel
like myself
and so many women i talked to have been
sorting through is
a lot of these guys are already getting
what they think they need so when i
might date a guy i'll look at his
instagram if he follows tons of porn
stars i don't even bother
that's that's wise i would say
they of course go that's insecure why
why can't i look at all these girls are
you insecure i'm like no no that's that
no
it's so amazing to me that anyone would
even think that that was
that that wasn't a valid thing to do i
can't believe you'd ever get criticized
for that that's
you know i was talking i talked to um
theodore dale rimple that's not his real
name it's anthony stevens a psychiatrist
you know and he
was he worked with he saw 15 000 people
who tried to commit suicide
yes wu is right and these were people
who were
at the bottom of the economic hierarchy
devastated lives and
these the women were often out with like
psychopathic brutes they were getting
beaten all the time
and there were markers for that shaved
head scars everywhere
tattoos on their fists love and hate
that sort of thing like obvious markers
you know oh yeah i should see those as
obvious markers they became so
fashionable
i just thought it was fashion but keep
going well and that that
that sort of thing also does happen but
his point was
there were these obvious markers but
they weren't being paid attention to
it's well what you just described well
that's an obvious marker to me
it's so obvious that i can't believe
that
you would be criticized for and to say
that that's a mark of insecurity
you know and i would also say it's
look here's here's one way of thinking i
thought about this it's like what's
what's the proper
domain for sexual morality what are the
right rules
don't do anything with anyone that you
couldn't talk to them about
if you feel uncomfortable talking about
what you're doing
you don't have a level of psychological
intimacy that should allow for that
level of physical intimacy
obviously jordan that's good
also it's a rule of thumb i would also
say that
general generally if you're female and
young and attractive
it's in your best interest and in the
best interest of the person that you're
dating to say
no for as long as you possibly can
if for no other reason then it's
without that well where's the game
where there's no game and you talked
about the chase you know and
like we have no idea how much
deprivation proper romance requires
but the answer is definitely not zero
because look
why otherwise what you meet up with
tinder let's say
you see you go to a special room you
both watch pornography you each have an
orgasm
that's your date well why not do that if
if that's what it's about that's simple
there's no mess
well there's some but only if it was fun
so but obviously nobody thinks about
that is ideal and that would be the
extreme case of contextless sexual
gratification
but that's really it's really
wrong it's wrong it just doesn't serve
anyone it's
terrible and it's it's that's the case
with this endless stream of available
pornography
it's a catastrophe that's what i think i
feel like we've
rewired especially young men um
women as well but especially young men
that are just men in general
that they're not even looking at women
as people most of the time
because even scrolling through instagram
you're seeing naked
people constantly it didn't used to be
like that 10 years ago
to see some a woman naked it was playboy
it was almost still special and not
i can remember the first time that i saw
a naked woman on
in in a video in a film in film was
actually if i remember correctly
it was in the life of brian the monty
python movie because there's a scene
where where one of the girlfriends of
one of the
uh revolutionary types opens the
curtains and she's naked and that's the
first time i saw
i think i had seen playboy pictures
before that
but it just blew me away i can remember
and i think i was about 13 or so and
you know it was a revelation of sorts
obviously
and now that's nothing that's nothing
it's nothing
that that's that's they're in in droves
any boy
can see more sexual imagery than anyone
ever saw in their whole life 30 years
ago
and i know that it's not directly
necessarily
linked but do you feel like that could
be
i this is my observation is a rise of
narcissism
do you think any of this could be linked
to the rise in narcissism
and self-involvement or is that still
just linked to
early childhood stuff i don't know
i don't know i mean to the degree that
sexual gratification through pornography
makes it possible to avoid the
complexities of a relationship
the advantages of a relationship in
modulating
sort of immature narcissistic
selfishness disappear
you know and i do think when it's it's
absolutely appropriate for young women
to
insist that they be treated the way they
would
like to be treated you should insist
upon that well your partner should as
well
insist upon that treatment for him but
so you have to sit down and think about
well how would you like to be treated if
you could have what you wanted
actually have it chapter three
yes well that yes and it's
for precisely those reasons that i that
i wrote it
but i love that
it's a funny thing to i i do believe
though that that's the case that
that you that know is the right answer
most of the time
it it's
it's disciplined that's part of it it's
provocative
that's part of it it's
guarding a secret it's it's it's it's
defending a treasure it's adding some of
the game
it's
and it's a demand that certain
preconditions have to be met
and it's the insistence that you be
regarded as a
complete person yes and now you know it
is going to be tempting to young women
too to separate their sexuality and say
well
i can go for instantaneous gratification
just like a man but
i do believe that men and women both pay
a tremendous price for instantaneous
sexual gratification
i'm i'm absolutely convinced of that but
i do believe that women pay a higher
price and the reason for that is that
sex is more dangerous for women and so
it's
it's it's it's it's
it's capacity to produce catastrophe is
heightened in women
and how could it be otherwise because
yeah that was like a bar
that was like wrapping what you just
said it's a catastrophe
that i liked it i'm gonna rewind this
and listen to that later i personally
like i i was all about yeah i can act
just like the guys and i can
hook up with all these people like when
i was much younger i was like i can be
just like them because that's
equal power that's equality and then i
looked at all these
female role models that i had these pop
stars these madonnas these whatever
none of them are doing okay now the one
you know like kind of the generation or
two generations above me that were
promoting
super promiscuity none of them have a
life
that i want now well look i'm old now
hey i'm 60 and my wife is 60 okay so
we're grandparents
and i can tell you what makes our lives
worthwhile
go on well i'm really attracted to my
wife get it girl
well we've been uh sorry
don't be sorry we've been uh isolated
from each other for a long time because
we're both so sick it's been two years
really
and the physical intimacy
element of our marriage is extremely
important we're very careful about that
and value it
extremely highly and pay a tremendous
amount of attention it's
really important that the sexual element
the romantic element
those ten those two things when they're
properly handled they're
indistinguishable
and if you think that sex is okay
without romance you don't know anything
about romance because sex is so much
better with romance that it's not even
the same thing
so so that's all important but
as you get older what's important is
that well you have a family you have
your children you have your
grandchildren you have a continuity of
narrative you have a long-term
relationship that you've built
yeah like that's that's what's important
and
when when you're doing things
impulsively when you're young you're
you're not paying attention to the old
you you have to have the old you in mind
you're going to be old and you have to
be building towards that
or you're going to be old and things are
going to be a catastrophe
so don't
this this you know this idea that you
said well i can be just like those men
it's like well you don't even
that isn't even the man you want yes why
would you imitate the man that you don't
want
yes yes jordan
you just i didn't even mean for this
conversation to go this way
i think what we've talked about in this
topic is so
important we're gonna rock some women
we're gonna rock some people back to
reality that's exactly what i did
i was impersonating men that i didn't
even want
they were the douche bags they were you
know the
the vagabonds the whatever we want to
call them the [ __ ]
oh look look there is okay so there's
something else which there's something
else we should sort out
okay there is an undeniable romantic
attraction
that men and women have to each other
for rule breakers
yes okay so you see badass women
who are very highly sexualized in the
movie screen all the time
but and so women do have some preference
for men who
are are wilder and who are capable of
breaking rules but
and that should be that should be
noticed and not ignored
but that doesn't mean that
they can break rules in other ways see
being a bad boy they should be able to
break them
yes but you can break a rule by breaking
a record by selling an awesome freaking
book and getting a new york times
bestseller
that's still breaking rules that we
should be looking at that as just as hot
which is why you have to be doing the
billboards well i think i think i think
i think that
i think that i think that by and large
women do
if they see that they do respond to it
but there's a disconnect sometimes the
simple rule breaking isn't
differentiated from the sophisticated
rule breaking
and so you you want to watch that
because that can get you in trouble
right because you'll be attracted to the
rebel anti-social type because you think
he's a rule-breaking hero but he's not
he's broken yeah that's yes that's
exactly right
he's not a conformist yeah but he
couldn't fit in
yeah that's not the same thing you want
someone who could fit in but breaks the
rules well that's
back to hermione i mean that's her gift
isn't it that's her
and all the whole harry potter crowd for
that matter is they they can
fit in in fact they're very good at it
they choose when to break the rules
and it works out yeah yes exactly and
it's what makes them attractive
characters as well
yes jordan peterson this was on my
bucket list
to have a chat with you so this has been
freaking awesome this is 12
questions with jordan peterson for
beyond order
12 more rules for life i freaking loved
our conversation
thank you so much my pleasure and i
i do think that we did something
different from the interviews that i
frequently have so that was very
interesting and entertaining